et que anthony brian logan blogueur
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir anthony
browne logan merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france les démocrates on
l'entend il parle d'un trop ce procès
truqué d'une parodie de pin résolution
déposée par le chef de la majorité
républicaine
est ce que vous partagez cette opinion
sur toute cette affaire est truqué c'est
une affaire politique
les démocrates n'ont jamais eu et juste
après une duration souhaitait se
débarrasser de lui il est déjà le
destituer d'autres personnes sont
[Musique]
parties au sein du parti démocrate ne
soit pas avoir en tant que président il
est certain que ont pour eux les rocades
l'élection présentielle n'était pas
favorable à l'or pour l'instant avant
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet et
d'aborder les chefs d'accusation qui
visent donald trump démocrates et
républicains débattent des règles du jeu
c'est en fait très technique quel est
l'enjeu de tout cela n'est qu'un jeu
l'importance de la procédure de
destitution
la discussion devrait être réservé à des
affaires très grave des deux crânes des
délits graves
mais ce n'est pas le cas ici donc si la
destitution continue alors la con c'est
dur sera utilisé à chaque fois qu'il ya
un désaccord politique qui pourrait être
utilisé la prochaine fois ci un
démocrate élu comme président et les
républicains pour essayer de se
débarrasser de lui via la destitution
cette procédure est vraiment détourné
c'est un embarras cement est ce que
finalement ce procès en destitution
n'est pas un coup d'épée dans l'eau
alors peut-être que c'est un feuilleton
qui intéresse les américains mais
d'une certaine manière les démocrates
sont évidemment contre donald trump et
les républicains pour le président des
états unis donc qu'est-ce que ça va
vraiment apporter selon vous est-ce que
ça peut changer quelque chose
des comédiens nous avons changé je pense
que les démocrates personnes qui
puissent devenir président en 2020
hillary clinton en 2016 était plus forte
à l'époque que tous les candidats
démocrates aujourd'hui et pourtant elle
a perdu c'était le deuxième tour d'une
présidence c'est dur de les sections est
donc juste un moyen d'essayer de se
débarrasser du président parce qu'ils
n'ont aucun maître recèle aucune façon
n'ont pas gagné donc ça j'y suis
rabattre sur des choses comme cela
néanmoins est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
est ce qu'il est possible en tout cas
qu'il y ait un coup de théâtre lors de
ces audiences qu'on apprenne peut-être
des choses qu'on ne savait pas qu'ils
puissent nuire au président un train
parce que nous avons déjà tout est
ouvert nous avons déjà toutes les
informations qui pourraient ressortir
lors de la rocha guns nancy pelosi a dit
que c'est lors de l'arrêt chagall est
que la procédure de destitution a été
lancée et après presque trois ans il ya
rien à nouveau n'est sorti de cette
affaire donc je ne pense pas qu'il va y
avoir deux nouveautés
parce que nous avons eu lieu en deux
temps un gamin de ressources
aujourd'hui l'attitude de donald trump
ne change pas c'est toujours la même
très sûr de lui il est en suisse à davos
il parle de chasse aux sorcières
aujourd'hui il n'y ronis même en disant
qu'il adorerait être là quelle est votre
réaction sur cette attitude son attitude
c'est parce qu'il sait que rien ne lui
arrivera il le précise
va bientôt être fils où il ne devait pas
durer encore longtemps peut-être une
semaine deux semaines au plus il n'y a
aucun risque de tout perdre son poste
il faudrait que vingt sénateurs votent
en faveur d'un retrait du président cela
n'arrivera pas s'il était vraiment
coupable d'un crâne alors on pourrait se
dire très bien destituant l'occurrence
n'est pas le cas on la procédure est et
partiel depuis le tout début donc son
attitude est très sûr car et il est
certain qu'il va rester à son poste et
que après la procédure de destitution on
pourra s'en servir lors de la campagne
pour dire à ses partisans que les
démocrates ont essayé de se débarrasser
de lui de lancer un renversement et qui
m'ont parlé ici et qu'il faut voter pour
lui en donne en vain d'autant plus que
personne à gauche ne peut leur verse le
battre est ce qu'un procès sans accusé
c'est vraiment un procès équitable des
charges dont habib faye bouquet le
procès de m et de l'est parce
qu'il n'a pas à grand chose à trouver
certains témoins sur cet être appelée à
comparaître mais cela ne fera pas de
différence en fin de compte si ce que
l'on appelle des jeux c'est moi ou pas
c'est toujours un exercice vides de sens
car depuis le début ce n'était pas un
véritable procès sommes donald trump l'a
dit c'est une blague rôle cela ne
devrait même pas avoir tout est le pro
la procédure de destitution ont détourné
de ses objectifs sera aussi juste que
possible car tu es le début n'aurait pas
dû y en avoir
aujourd'hui ça sera ma dernière question
qu'est ce qui différencie ce procès en
destitution de donald trump est ce que
bill clinton avait vécu à l'époque de la
sphère levinsky en termes de résonance
aux états unis voir ce qu'il y avait
j'ai des problèmes même s'ils s'allègent
de la destitution
la situation actuelle est bien plus
partiale bien plus partisane la
différence clé entre la destitution des
tons à 30 pour celles que personne ne
viser après l'élection de bill clinton
qu'ils allaient essayer de restituer le
jour de son inauguration
parce que donald trump a été élu et les
gens ont rapidement commencé à dire que
voulait le destituer alors qu'elle ait
encore aucune cause ne parlait pas
encore de la fer russes et on ne parlait
pas encore de toutes les autres affaires
dont la destruction a toujours hanté de
notre un peu mais pas bill clinton
merci beaucoup anthony à brens logan
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes blogueur politique merci à
vous